welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode 2. my breakdown of
episode one is already on the channel
but I had to do a breakdown of episode
two separately because the starter voice
is these breaks are fermented out there
sir Punk hits a full mint in eastern
eggs if this show feels like a Prestige
HBO drama it's because the casting
apartment dug deep into the talent pool
of HBO's Chernobyl three of them but
let's break down all the subtle details
that make me love this series
after the opening title shots including
b2emo with the droids and that and or
title with the rebel sigil notice
Nicholas bertel's music is slightly
different from episode 1 episode 2.
yeah Brazil adds a bit more of a Gallop
to these strings as Cassie in this
episode has to pick up his Pace to stay
on the move from the forces now hunting
him down even in the final shot of the
episode our man has to break into a jog
but we open on qunari in another
flashback as young Casa's Alpha tribe
hikes to the crash site a reptilian
creature or a large insect crawls down a
tree now at first we assume this thing's
head was at the top until it moves we
realized we had it backwards such as the
case with Cassian Andor on this show
he's not truly defined until the guy has
to move out of his stasis as before we
do not get subtitles for these qunari
kids nor do we need them notice they all
wear a scavenged ill-fitting clothes of
yellow orange and brown colors one
girl's clothes actually look like the
orange rebel pilot flight suit whereas
the taller older kids can all step over
that fallen tree to hop over it young
Cassie is too short and has to sit on it
and drag his butt over it which is why
he's having trouble keeping up but they
pass this vast pit that has been
abandoned and based on the dozens and
dozens of Terror addresses it has been
dug dozens of layers deep we cannot even
see the full rock bottom of this pit you
can see all these cave-ins on various
sizes that have taken out the machinery
and the infrastructure so this project
might have been attacked or bombed or
sabotaged in some way and shortly after
Left Behind not even cleaned up my
theory is that Cassian and all these
other Alphas might have been the
children of these excavators who died in
the cave-ins and the reason that their
clothes all matched and do not fit well
is because those are the clothes of
their parents and other workers who are
working on the site who died all this
could explain why Cassian looks out at
this pit with this look of wistfulness
now back on ferricks there's a man
accredited As Time Grappler a job that I
would love to have and he readies
himself in the Bell Tower
foreign
ERS just by sitting them down in the
middle of that Bell now this time
Grapplers played by actor Neil Bell and
no perfect name right but this guy
actually appeared in Dune as the starter
car Bashar where he got to show off his
amazing vocal Talent
Ed now
I want to quash a rumor right now that's
going around about me I am not I repeat
not a duck I'm not a duck a lot of you
are out there saying oh Eric's gonna be
a duck since he loves having his wet
feet well I don't I don't like wet Pete
I like my feet to be nice and dry which
is why I've got a pair of best seats
yeah I know what a segue but we got
there thanks the bestie for sponsoring
this video and helping me prove that I'm
not a duck bestie's here to keep you
looking good while keeping your feet dry
besties are the perfect everyday shoe
they're sustainably made knit sneakers
that are 100 waterproof they're made
with this diamond text material that's
super easy to clean with just a rinse of
water
no I spilled water all over my pizza
Wheaties but my Oinky oinkies are brown
trying like the Dune seeds thanks Messi
if the weather is wet or if it's muddy
best seats can help unless you're a duck
which I'm not because then you'd already
have your duck feet for the rest of us
there's Bessie vessies are my go-to
shoes check them out in the link below
for your pair of your own invest these
shoes now notice how this Bell is a
piece of metal folded on itself so that
no part touches another part and based
on the swirls of black and that gray
metal this might be beskar now we know
from the Mandalorian in the book of it
that there was an imperial Purge on
Mandalore taking all that planet's best
scar but since Andor is set in 5 BBY
that would be years after this I just
love how dedicated this time Grappler is
to his job there's no audience watching
him his movements are a kind of routine
discipline rage exertion calculated to
produce the most harmonic sound as
possible from this metal because this is
a crucial function for the entire
working Town not only do they similarly
bang metal to signal each other next
episode here everyone sets their clocks
to this the shipyard the scrap workers
the shopkeeps and so we see why Cassian
needed such a firm Alibi this town does
not stay awake at night there's kind of
a self-enforced curfew now as pegla
turns off the shipyard lights a few
gaunt Birds Peck at the Machinery which
I'm pretty sure are practical puppets
unfortunately these guys do not appear
here in the next wide shot though which
is a shame these Disney Haunted Mansion
Birds need to be everywhere these birds
actually look like the steel pecker
puppets that we saw in jakku and the
force awakens but with their beaks
painted black now the ships in this yard
are all familiar models the one closest
to pegla is the cockpit of a y-wing
painted yellow but its back engines
might not be fully intact yet it might
be because the rebels would only now
starting to be using these fighters from
the income Corporation across the way on
the right painted blue and white looks
like the same model as the best Dune
Legacy that's Ochi Starship from the
rise of Skywalker and then in the back
on the right that looks like the vcx
wanted your light braider the same kind
of model as the ghost Harrison doula's
ship and Rebels now Bix and Tim see the
message that zero car in order to be
flooded onto ferricks's comms three more
zakarity seeking a canary male resident
of ferrix for questioning citizens with
any information please contact the
pre-works more a lot of security without
delay so it's not really common in Star
Wars for human characters to be
physically identified by their home
planets like this like it probably has
happened it's just not very common like
humans from Tatooine don't really look
any different than humans from Naboo
planets from corellia despite the vastly
different climates on those planets but
remember last episode implied that
qunari is coded to mean having dark
features and there's definitely a
parallel here in the way that real world
apbs often go out describing suspects
with certain physical features this
series's first few episodes proceed with
the pace and setting and theme similar
to The Slow Burn of things like Spike
Lee's do the right thing and HBO is the
wire really we're just living in a few
days of a working life of an oppressed
people with tensions rising and rising
and rising to a boiling point
intercutting with cops who completely
misunderstand this community and really
just because they're trying to avoid the
ire of their bosses we're completely
disconnected from everything Cassian
returns home to meet Marva played by
Fiona Shaw and it looks like Cassian
pours himself some blue milk from a
bottle of course that's the Bantham milk
that amparoo pours in the 1977 film and
shows up in Rogue one in the opening
scene Marva has B2 read allow the
security posts and asks Cassian who else
knows he's from qunari we have always
said first every doc I've ever submitted
has always said you were born on fist
have you ever said anything other than
this best is an outer rim Planet first
mentioned in Rogue one visual guide
planet to get Savage by the Empire
creating a kind of refugee crisis
Cassian snaps at Marva for telling close
friends Jesse and Samo that he came from
qunari but Marvel lists off all of his
women stop stop stop there's something I
don't even know oh let's not forget
Monica Erica Rita Tina Sandra Mary and
Jessica now we learned that marva's name
is Marva Andor so the name Andor came
from her in this home hang some yellow
and red work gloves these might be the
ones missing from the wall last episode
assuming they belong to Marva this tells
us that Marva had continued to work for
a long time and only stopped recently
when she got sick that's explaining why
she needed medicine delivered B2 reveals
Bix tried to contact him but cassian's
cons failed setting up Cassian insisting
that b2uscoms at the end of this episode
which we find out in episode 3 is quite
an over correction Cassian meets Bix
later in a bar and thanks her for
summoning her contact we see how he has
wrapped his hand and rubs his knuckles
in this moment trying to hide the bloody
knuckles he got when he fought those
cops that he killed but Tim overseas
this and drunk snitches on Cassian the
screen at first reads insert credits and
then call Link in orbash I love how that
alien one phone over grumbles and turns
away annoyed to have some privacy back
in Orlando 1 the incoming screen reads
wanted for questioning at the top and
then at the bottom it lists charges in
this Orlando one officer reads off
cassian's past charges Insurrection
destruction of Imperial property assault
an imperial Soldier now this hollow
projected mugshot of Cassian seems to be
a younger image of Diego Luna either DH
or maybe photos taken during Rogue one's
production either way he does not yet
have the Shiner that he has in these
episodes back on ferricks a close-up of
Tim's dinner shows more blue food in
this case it kind of looks like blue
Cheerios or like fruit loops oops all
blue ones and Karn meets Sergeant Linus
mosque aka the Dwight Schrute of
morelana one velocity in the service of
inspired leadership is there a worthy
substitute nothing not he has played
amazingly by Alex ferns aka the badass
coal miner and Chernobyl who strips down
naked and dig a runoff tunnel beneath
the radiation leak in he's also
commissioner Pete Savage in the Batman
this guy's having a moment and Linus
says I've seen it some half measures to
take it slow to wait and see it's a
plague on discipline face your man
yourself the rest of your life knowing
you did less than everything you
possibly could yeah there's a subtlest
implication here that mosque might have
let an opportunity for advancement go by
in the past and he's been kicking
himself ever since and he goes on with
my favorite line of this episode it's
fermenting out there so
pockets of fermenting and the best way
to keep the bleach sharp is to use it
pockets of fomenting in a river we know
corn love to tailor his pockets so
mosque must know the way to karn's heart
is through them actually podcaster Holly
Frey on Twitter made an awesome Thread
about how Cyril Karns costume might have
actually been tailored uniquely by the
show's costume Department compared to
the other primordial uniforms like
mosques to show how he actually stitched
part of the seam on his shoulder Cassian
retrieves from a hidden compartment on
the ship his ns9 star path unit where
indeed that Imperial seal is still
intact back in the qunari flashback the
lead girl silently slides down the dirt
into the debris trench where yellow gas
continues to waft up from the wreckage
then we see Luth and Rael making his
approach toward Barracks pilot in a
fondor hall craft with a fondor Droid
mod AI voice assisting him bondor is a
planet known for its industrial
shipyards and purple inhabitants
mentioned in comics like Han Solo at
Star's end and Darth Vader strikes then
as a Time Grappler wakes up the town Bix
wakes up to the super comforting sight
of her previous tonight's hookup sitting
in a chair staring at her she asks for
calf which is the in-universe Star Wars
term for copy so Cassian gives B2 these
comms and B reminds him that only
Cassian knows where marva's cache of
credits are so if you were to die or get
captured I'd have to leave those credits
would be lost and as Marva looks for B
we see that there is a bantha figurine
on the Shelf those are the big riding
beasts that we see on Tatooine I got to
meet a big talk and puppet version at
Star Wars celebration I love these
things and also she finds the staff
weapon that Cassian carried with him as
a kid on qunari confirmed to us that he
has been in this room since he was a kid
or like me he's just a grown adult who
likes to keep Star Wars toys lying
around back in the flashback the alpha
see the crew of that crashed ship some
with gas masks over their faces all of
their skin tainted yellow from the
chemical detonation but their uniforms
bear the logo of the separatist hex icon
so this is during the Clone Wars and
these are separatists part of the
Confederacy of independent systems this
is probably in the final years of the
Clone Wars now the separatists that she
passed before Rises and immediately
shoots her in the back what a jerk this
girl's name sounds something like monitu
or moniku based on what the other kids
are calling her the others take down the
separatists with blow darts and cry and
carry off her body but Cassian stays
behind because he wants a taste of the
goods meanwhile adult Cassian approaches
San Juan shop the orbit on the outside
of the building translates to San Juans
and Cassian fears that the guy
researched about the planet qunari
kanari mid Rim abandoned after Imperial
mining disaster
mining everyone died abandoned and
considered toxic Imperial prohibition
this might be the first time Cassian has
heard how his home planet is listed but
it's interesting for them to call it an
imperial mining disaster when those
separatist patches would have placed
this probably before the Empire but
maybe there was something else going on
there like maybe there was a kind of War
crime that the imperial records now one
to cover up by calling it just a mining
disaster or maybe something even worse
happened there after all this went down
either way Cassie is now hearing how he
left his sister behind on a toxic planet
now Karn and his unit travel through
hyperspace from marlona 1 to pharynx
which is a bit odd because I thought
they were part of the same system
passion I don't think needed to go
through hyperspace to go for more Lana 1
to pharynx so would they need a
hyperspace jump to get there I don't
know maybe I'm overthinking in but Linus
says then maybe some local residents who
are
lesson enthused for that presence
you may remind them that there's a
territorial Forum once a month where
they are free to make official
complaints now notice how the younger
soldiers stop at this well it looks like
the older ones remain Stone paced it's
probably because these older guys
remember a time before the Empire and
before primor's contract and therefore
might have a better idea of the rough
types they're about to face on Barracks
meanwhile Karen gives just a dog [ __ ]
motivational speech there's no room for
doubt on the path to
success
and uh
Justice
best of luck to us all and just how bad
his speech is and their lack of
enthusiasm just shows how these are not
trained soldiers looking for a fight
they are private security dragged into
this mission that they don't really care
about now we get this nice quiet moment
on the shuttle into town when Luther
gets pulled into small talk about how
they are circling the landing Zone kind
of like when you're on a flight and the
guy next to you is like oh we're just
circling LAX this flight was so
expensive what are we paying for this
guy's name is Willie and he's played by
Ron Cook both he and Stellan Skarsgard
appeared in the show Chernobyl Skarsgard
of course says serbina and cook as a
maternity doctor if you have not seen
Chernobyl yet it is probably the best
thing that's come out on HBO in the past
few years now it's always interesting to
hear the older characters of this era
talk because they've seen so much change
over their lifetimes including Willie
here I'm old enough I first came here to
drive in across the Wasteland they had a
ground carry drive right through that
was no bargain either you make the round
trip and taste it a week later just
then I'll stay yeah that Tasty's
referring to in his mouth was likely the
iron powder from the barracks surface
and what does iron taste like it is the
taste of blood this is at least partly
why luthin likely resents this
propulsion dealer Lutheran totally would
have preferred taking ground
transportation but only took this
commercial shuttle to avoid suspicion he
is not disturbed by the taste of blood
in one's mouth and Willie leaves him
with if you can't find it here it's not
worth finding and we end on the item
Lutheran is truly looking for not that
ns9 unit with The Unbroken Imperial seal
but somewhat Deft enough to steal
something like that Cassian and or and
to protect himself the Blaster that cast
and Carries is actually the k-16 Briar
pistol from the dark Forces game the
weapon carried by Kyle katarn a
character that many believe actually
inspired the character of Cassian Andor
when they were creating him for rogue
one now again my breakdown of episode 1
is already on the Channel episode 3's
breakdown is going to be coming up as
soon as we can get up tomorrow you can
follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at E A Boss fall into rockstars
And subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]